[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
mietri Sirin in allen einen schönen
guten Abend den sonntagsporttag später
wieder Norbert im Blick schönen Abend
noch von mir und hier sind unsere Themen
Ortstermin vor Afrikas Küste
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
erläutert auf der italienischen Insel
Lampedusa die Europa die illegale
Einwanderung eindämmen will
gute Nachrichten für Erfurt die UNESCO
Ertas mittelalterliche jüdische Erbe in
Thüringens Landeshauptstadt mit dem
Welterbetitel
und Matchbälle verwandelt Deutschlands
Tischtennis Damen verteidigen ihren
Europameistertitel gegen die Dauer
Rivalinnen aus Rumänien
Italiens Insel Lampedusa ist zum Synonym
für eine bislang gescheiterte
eu-flüchtlingspolitik geworden weil
zuletzt wieder tausende geflüchtete dort
ankamen forderte Rom zuletzt einen
eu-einsatz der flüchtlingsbote stoppt
weil das Thema viel politischen
Sprengstoff birgt reiste
kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
heute nach Lampedusa Christian Volk
den Hafen von Lampedusa verstopfen noch
immer zurückgelassene Flüchtlingsboote
in den vergangenen Tagen kamen tausende
Migranten hier an heute stehen die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin und die
italienische Regierungschefin am Anleger
Grund die Insel mit ihren 6.500
Einwohnern ist mit den vielen
Flüchtlingen überfordert so dürfe es
nicht weitergehen sagt von der Leyen
wir haben eine Verpflichtung als Teil
der internationalen Gemeinschaft die
haben wir in der Vergangenheit erfüllt
und das machen wir auch weiter aber wir
entscheiden wer in die EU kommt und
unter welchen Umständen und nicht die
Schmuggler und Menschenhändler
im Gepäck hat von der Leyen einen zehn
Punkteplan darin enthalten eine stärkere
Überwachung der EU-Außengrenze eine
bessere Verteilung der Flüchtlinge und
Kooperationen mit deren Herkunftsländern
nicht enthalten melonis Forderung
illegale Migranten notfalls mit der
Marine an der Überfahrt nach Europa zu
hindern
wir werden das Problem nicht lösen wenn
wir darüber reden wie wir die
Flüchtlinge innerhalb Europas
umverteilen können die einzige
Möglichkeit ist die illegale Ausreise
von Migranten zu stoppen
auch eine geplante
eu-asylrechtsreform ist durch die
Situation auf Lampedusa in Gefahr
Brüssel braucht Italien als
Kooperationspartner sollte das Land nun
eigenständig zu härteren Maßnahmen
greifen um Migranten abzuwehren wäre ein
europäischer Konsens wohl gescheitert
eine Woche ist es her dass schwere
Überschwemmungen libyenheim suchten in
den flutgebieten so hieß es heute von
den Vereinten Nationen sein mindestens
11.300 Menschen ums Leben gekommen
weitere 10.000 würden vermisst aber die
Behörden bestätigen das nicht klar ist
nur das Ausmaß der Zerstörung ist
gewaltig und das Leid etwa indirner
riesig goldener teil
eine Woche nach der Katastrophe
offenbart des Meer seinen Schrecken
hunderte Leichen haben Rettungskräfte in
einer Bucht gefunden gehen oder bleiben
viele Einwohner in Derna klammern sich
an die Überreste ihres alten Lebens erst
einmal müssten sie das Geschehene
begreifen sagen sie
wir wissen noch nicht wie es weitergeht
wir hören Gerüchte über eine Evakuierung
andere sagen wir könnten bleiben aber
wir haben keinen Strom kein Wasser
nichts zum Leben
eine Einwohnerin versucht im Knöchel
tiefen Schlamm ihrer Wohnung noch
irgendetwas zu retten in dem Haus der
sie und ihr Mann einst Stück für Stück
mühsam gebaut hatten ich habe den Tod
mit eigenen Augen gesehen meine Familie
war kurz davor zu sterben
in den Fluten erklärt ihr Mann hielt
sich die ganze Familie an einem rohrfest
sie überlebten
im Angesicht der Massengräber überlegen
die Helfer derweil wie sie die zweite
Katastrophe in der verhindern können
die Brunnen hier sind mit Abwasser
kontaminiert Cholera und
Leberkrankheiten werden sehr
wahrscheinlich die Folge sein
sauberes Wasser wird gebraucht und
mindestens genauso dringend
psychologische Unterstützung für die
Opfer
bei den Ausschreitungen rund um das
eritrea-festival in Stuttgart gestern
hat es 228 Festnahmen gegeben das teilte
die Polizei heute mit Gegner und
Befürworter der eritreischen Regierung
gerieten aneinander dabei wurden auch
Polizisten angegriffen und 27 verletzt
innenministerinnen Feder verurteilte die
Gewalt scharf bei Eritrea
Veranstaltungen gab es zuletzt mehrfach
Ausschreitungen
in Berlin haben klimaaktivisten der
sogenannten letzten Generation das
Brandenburger Tor mit Farbe besprüht die
Polizei nahm 14 Personen fest ermittelt
wird jetzt wegen Sachbeschädigung die
letzte Generation hatte angekündigt den
Schwerpunkt ihrer Proteste in die
Hauptstadt zu verlegen
Mindestlohn Vermögenssteuer und
Tarifabschlüsse um das und mehr geht es
beim wer die Bundeskongress in Berlin
Unterstützung für viele Ziele gab es
heute vom Bundeskanzler welchen
politischen Kurs sich die Gewerkschaft
für die nächsten Jahre vorstellt dazu
Hans-jürgen Piel
morgen braucht uns das Kongress Moto
lässt keinen Zweifel deutschlands
zweitgrößte Gewerkschaft sieht sich nach
erfolgreicher Tarifrunde im öffentlichen
Dienst
igkeit und auch
eine Teilung deshalb ist unsere
Botschaft klar Steuern hoch für Reiche
und für Krisengewinner tausend
Delegierte und prominente Gäste zur
Eröffnung auf dem Verdi Bundeskongress
mit einem Bundeskanzler der sagt was
hier gut ankommt die Grundlage für gute
Löhne ist neben einer ordentlichen
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung immer auch
tarifpartnerschaft und Tarifverträge sie
sind das stabile Fundament unseres
Landes und wir brauchen mehr
Tarifverträge und nicht weniger herr
Scholz fast ein Heimspiel viele Verdi
Forderungen sind auch spd-positionen
doch die Gewerkschaft drückt
Mitgliederschwund seit Gründung hat
Verdi von 2,8 Millionen Mitgliedern mehr
als ein Drittel verloren immerhin
während und nach den Arbeitskämpfen vom
Frühjahr traten 140.000 Menschen neu ein
womöglich die Trendwende
das ist ein großes Hoffnungszeichen weil
Gewerkschaften brauchen Mitglieder ohne
Mitglieder sind sie nicht sichtbar sind
sie nicht kampffähig sind sie nicht
durchsetzungsfähig und wie das
weitergeht kann man insofern schwer
einschätzen morgen wird der
Gewerkschaftsvorstand neu gewählt an
einer Wiederwahl Frankreich wird nicht
gezweifelt
wunderbar die chinesische Mauer oder die
Akropolis in Athen beides
Weltkulturerbestätten auf die
renommierte Liste der UNESCO hat es
heute auch Erfurt mit seinen jüdisch
mittelalterlichen Bauten in der Altstadt
dazu Daniela Sonntag
Jubel auf denen die Erfurter 15 Jahre
lang hingearbeitet haben heute nun die
Entscheidungen Riad die jüdischen
Städten in Erfurt sind Welterbe wir sind
jetzt auf einer Ebene in einer Liga mit
mit den Pyramiden in Ägypten mit mit mit
mit der chinesischen Mauer mit Machu
Picchu das ist schon das ist schon was
besonderes ein großes Erbe der jüdische
Schatz mit dem berühmten Hochzeitsring
ausgestellt an einem ganz besonderen Ort
der Alten Synagoge teils tausend Jahre
alt genutzt als Lager und tanzal
überlebte das Gotteshaus auch den Nazi
Terror erst Ende der 90er legte ein
Abriss von Nachbarhäusern die alte
jüdische Geschichte wieder frei
dass hier eben einer Synagoge mit den
ältesten Teilen aus dem 11 jahrhundert
heute noch steht bis zur Dachkante aus
mittelalterliche Substanz besteht heute
benutzbar ist das ist wirklich
außergewöhnlich zum Welterbe gehört auch
die mique das rituelle jüdische Bad und
das sogenannte steinerne Haus Erfurt ist
damit das zweite Welt Erbe in
Deutschland mit jüdischen Städten das
ist auch etwas was in die Zukunft weiß
das bedeutet Zusammenhalt das bedeutet
sich unsere Geschichte bewusst zu sein
und das bedeutet auch eine große
vermittlungsaufgabe so soll auch ein
Infozentrum fürs Welterbe entstehen aber
heute erstmal feiern
jetzt zum Sport Norbert Deutschlands
tischtennismänner die stehen gerade eben
EM-Finale und die Frauen haben den ja
schon geholt ja ein Titelverteidigung
erfüllt durch einen souveränen 3:0 Sieg
im Finale gegen Rumänien im Nachmittag
in Malmö und die vorzeitige
Qualifikation für Olympia in Paris ist
damit auch geschafft
zum sechsten Mal kommen die
finalgegnerinnen aus Rumänien zum
vierten Mal gewinnt Deutschland chirona
San schlägt zum Auftakt Elisabeth Samara
klar in drei Sätzen nach dem Sieg von
yin-han im zweiten Einzel macht es Nina
Mittel haben noch einmal spannend gegen
Andrea Dragoman muss sie im fünften Satz
sogar zwei matchspiele abwehren kurz
darauf erster Matchball für mittelham
sie gewinnt damit den entscheidenden
Satz Deutschlands Frauen sind ohne ein
verlorenes Spiel Europameisterinnen und
feiern den insgesamt 9 EM-Titel
nach knapp zwei Jahren ist Stefan Kuntz
als Fußball-Nationaltrainer der Türkei
entlassen worden der Verband trennte
sich nach der jüngsten zwei zu viel
Niederlage gegen Japan vom 60-Jährigen
im ersten Sonntagsspiel der
Fußball-Bundesliga der Männer hat
Aufsteiger Heidenheim den ersten Saison
Siegerehrung durch das 14:2 gegen Werder
Bremen ja und in der Fußball-Bundesliga
der Frauen da hat Köln knapp mit 2:1
gegen Leipzig gewonnen und die
Vizemeisterin aus Wolfsburg gegen Bayer
Leverkusen souverän mit 13:0
für Wolfsburgs meine frommes weiß ein
gemütlicher Nachmittag im eigenen
Stadion wurde die nationaltöterin nicht
wirklich geprüft gegen Leverkusen er
spielte sich der VfL Chance und Chance
braucht aber 15 Minuten zum 1:0 durch
Lena Oberdorf sechs Minuten später dann
das 2:0 durch Lena Latein gleichzeitig
der Pausenstand nach dem Wechsel
gelingen zwei emissionsortier im
Nachsetzen noch das 3:0 für Wolfsburg
ein ungefährdete Auftakt in die neue
Bundesliga-Saison das ohne viel Tamtam
stark Würfeln vielleicht gibt's ja
wieder entspannenden Zweikampf mit den
Bayern um die Meisterschaft schauen wir
mal vielen Dank Norbert wir blicken noch
gemeinsam auf die Wetter Aussichten erst
im Westen dann aber auch in der Mitte
Schauer und Gewitter im Osten länger
sonnig und bis zum abendbrocken die
Höchstwerte zwischen 22 Grad an der
Nordsee und 30 Grad in Brandenburg ja
das war schon wieder von uns zum 21:45
Uhr sehen Sie das heute journal mit
Christian Sievers schönen Dank schönen
Abend und jetzt schön dran bleiben bei
Berlin direkt mit Theo